What August the fourth 1892 Andrew and
Abby Borden were brutally matters in
their home in fall river,
Massachusetts.
Their heads had been split open in a fit
of rage from nearly a dozen blows from
a hatchet. There was no theft.
There was no sign of a break.
In the 32 year old daughter Lizzie Borden
was at home when their parents were
killed.
She inherited her father's multimillion
dollar fortune and everyone in fall
river believed that she had killed her
parents in cold blood. But in the end,
that simply was not enough evidence to
convict her and she was allowed to go
free. Nearly 120 years later, the
case is still an unsolved mystery.
So did Lizzie Borden really kill her
parents or is the identity of the real
killer still unknown?
Yeah.
Andrew Borden came from a long line
of wealthy and successful people,
but his own parents struggled
with poverty. As a young man,
he started working as an underwriter
at a bank in fall river, Massachusetts.
He used his paychecks to
purchase investment real
estate and ran furniture and
textile businesses. He was eventually
promoted as the manager of the bank,
even though he was making a lot of money.
He only paid for the band necessities
for himself and for his family is
fortunate.
It grew to over $300,000 which in
modern day dollars is about 8 million.
He married a woman named Sarah Anthony
Moss and they had three children together.
Emma was the oldest. They had a second
daughter named Dallas who don't as a baby.
Lizzie Borden was the youngest daughter
born in 1860 when she was only two years
old and this, these mother Sarah became
gravely ill and I was 12 at the time,
so she was old enough to remember the
death of her sister and fully understood
the gravity of losing their mother on
her deathbed am I swore to take care of
baby Lizzie like a mother, and she
took that promise incredibly seriously.
Three Years After Sarah Staff Andrew Board
and married a woman named Abby Duffy,
who was 15 at the time,
refused to address Abby as mother and
it's called her by her first name,
her entire childhood. There's, he grew
up to be very close with her sister Emma,
who truly did feel more like a mother
to have in a big sister. However,
this backfired because teenage Emma was
constantly reminding her younger sister
that their birth mother was debt.
Because of this,
Lizzy never formed a close
relationship with her stepmother.
She leads to describe that
relationship is cordial,
but she grew up feeling as though she
never really knew a mother's love.
We don't know much about the intimate
details of there's these relationship with
our father accepts that he was a very
busy man as he had a full time job and
also ran his own businesses on the side.
There's, he claims to love him very much,
but it's true business tactics and lack
of empathy for customers defaulting on
some of their loans because some people
in town to dislike him as well as his
family. Lizzie Borden's elementary school
teachers described her as being aloof,
so she was either painfully shy or
felt as though she didn't want to make
friends. She was also for
having dramatic mood swings.
She could either be very
relaxed and unemotional or
she could burst out in a fit
of rage.
This is not uncommon for children who
have lost their parents at a young age,
but she was severely neglected considering
for tragedy that had before than
their family.
The wealthy members of the extended board
and family lived in mansions up in a
fashionable neighborhood called hell.
They enjoy,
it's an easy life with teams of seven so
that they can call Andrew Borden on the
other hands,
rented half of a duplex for his family
and waited until this children were grown
to buy that house and combine
both harvest and do a single home.
He never installed electricity or indoor
plumbing even though it was actually
quite affordable at that time.
As she grew older and as he began to
learn more about her extended family who
lived up on the hill,
her cousins were always attending
parties and dances and went to the local
theater together with young
people their own age does.
He wanted to join the rest of our friends,
but Andrew Board and thought that these
activities were simply a waste of money.
He never gave his daughters and allowance
to attend any of these social outings
living in a working class neighborhood
unless he seemed far too rich to fit in
where they lived,
and yet their father never gave them
money to socialize up on the hill.
They were stuck in an isolating situation
and they felt like outcasts or cousins
or married rich man and their fathers
paid dowries to help them buy their own
houses.
Meanwhile,
Lizzy and Emma were still living with
their parents as their only social
interactions came from
church related events.
Lizzie Borden really only had one close
friends and that was her neighbor,
Alice Russell.
Many people who knew Lizzie Borden before
the murders said that she was a gentle
person with a kind heart.
She was leave slices of chocolate cake
for men who came to her father's house
for maintenance and insisted on tipping
the groundskeeper whenever her father
was too cheap to do it himself.
She also gave candy to local children
along with cards that were signed from
Auntie Borden, even though women were
not allowed to hold a job at the time.
Lizzie kept herself busy.
She taught Sunday school to the
local children in fall river,
and most people in town knew of her as
being a very pious and a religious woman.
She was also heavily involved
in local women's charity groups.
Washing testified that she
loved her father very much less.
He fundamentally disagreed in
the way he handled his money.
She also believed that her step mother
was trying to take advantage of his
fortune when she was 27 years old.
Lizzie's father gave a house to
his wife's half sister for free.
This made busy Emma furious because they
were his own daughters and yet he had
never given them such an extravagant gift.
When he realized how unfair this was,
he gave his daughters the deed to the
house he grew up into try and pacify them.
However,
there was a strict code of etiquette that
unmarried women could not live alone.
Since Lizzie and Emma never found husbands
owning the deed to that grandfather's
home was virtually useless and they
were never allowed to move out of their
father's house.
They eventually sold the house back to
their father for $5,000 even after doing
this, it was still not enough
to make up for the jealousy.
I'm the resentments that there's,
he felt towards her step mother Abbey.
Lizzie Borden was unhappy living with
her father and her stepmother and she
spent as much time as possible out of
the house soon after the arguments about
the houses Andrey board and agreed
to let he visit Europe. But the trip,
I only made her realize just how much
she had missed in her younger years.
When she retired in times
of the United States,
she often chosen not to eat meals with
our parents and went up to the bedroom
without even saying hello
live in the boarding house.
It went on like this for several more
years in 1892 does he bought was 32 years
old and her sister Emma was 42 neither
of them had gotten married in the 18
hundreds this made them spinsters
women who were considered to be 40 well
defined her husbands. There is no
record of why they never married,
but their family issues clearly
had something to do with that.
Lizzy continue to devote herself to the
church as well as local animal rescue.
She was raising a family of pigeons on
that property and she loved them like
perhaps in June of that same year entry
purchase the hatchet and started killing
Lizzie's bad so that he
could save money on meat.
Lizzy may have felt that how a
window of opportunity to escape this
dysfunctional family and find a
better life was closing in on her.
Her father was 70 years old and she
needed to face the possibility that he may
die soon if there's money was
controlled by her stepmother.
She knew things would get
much worse at any moment.
Lizzie Borden and to
assist to Emma's lives,
we're going to be over unless
he did something to stop it.
As we mentioned earlier,
Andrew and Abby board and were murdered
on August the fourth 1892 the events
leading up to them murders may give a
clue as to what may have really happened
on that fateful day.
On August the second the entire
board and family was feeling sick.
I'll be bored and visited her local
doctor asking if it was possible that have
bread had been poisoned.
Her doctor said that it was
far more likely that she
simply ate some rotten meat
and that everyone in the house
was suffering from food poisoning.
This was not uncommon back then since
there were no refrigerators to keep meat
and cheese from going
bad in the summer heat.
On August the third the
night before the murders,
Lizzie and Emma's uncle John Moss showed
up and announced he did not bring any
luggage, but he asked to
stay over night. John Moss,
he was the brother of Sarah Moss,
Andrew's first wife and the girls
biological uncle. For whatever reason,
this named Lizzie Borden feel uneasy.
She told her friends, Alice Russell,
but she was terrified that
someone was about to the family.
According to his testimony,
John boss woke up at 6:00 AM the next day.
On August the fourth rigid,
the maid cooked food for her master's
and gassed and serve their breakfast to
Abby,
Andrew and John.
Around 7:00 AM Jon announced that he was
going to see his other relatives town
and his left the house at around
eight 30 in the morning there's,
he said that she was feeling sick so she
never said hello to her uncle law came
down to eat breakfast with our family.
Andrew Borden went to work at the bank
around 9:00 AM according to the maid
rigid Mrs Borden Asta to wash the windows
outside that day and she said that she
would have makes the bet and do
the laundry in the guest bedroom.
When Bridgette was done
washing the windows,
she was feeling exhausted from
working in the summer. He,
since she was still sick to her stomach,
she had been vomiting in the backyard
and desperately needed some rest.
Andrew was feeling sick at work,
so he returns home around 11:00 AM but
all of the doors were locked with a
deadbolt, so is key to the
front door. It wouldn't work.
This was strange and he pounded on the
door to have someone let him in rigid
rush in the front door and unlocked it.
Andrew Board and decided to take
a nap on the living room couch,
hoping that he could sleep off his
sickness during his lunch break.
Bridget saw this as an
opportunity to rest,
so she went up to her bedroom in
the ASIC to take an APP as well.
Lizzy claims that she had to go outside
to the bond and look for a fishing lure
for a trip that she was taking.
The following weekend's according to
her testimony during that small 10 to 15
minute window of time outside,
someone had taken a hatchet to
our father's face at 11 times.
His eyeballs were cut in half.
His nose was gone and he was barely
recognizable as a person anymore. There's,
he walked back into the house and when
she saw a father's mutilated body,
she screamed. She called to Bridget,
does how hard that her father was dead.
She ran next door to a neighbor called
Adelaide Churchill saying, I miss this.
Churchill do come over.
Someone has killed father.
They notified the police and the family
doctor. You arrive to examine the body.
By that time,
everyone in the neighborhood knew about
the crime and re Borden's wounds were
still fresh. It's suggesting that the
attack had happened very recently.
There's his friend Alice Russell rushed
over to the house to see what was wrong.
Lizzie, she was hysterical and
leaned on. Alice for comfort.
Lizzy asked Bridget to check upstairs
for her step mother saying, well,
someone find Mrs Borden.
This is Borden was lying face down on
the floor of one of the guest bedrooms.
She had also been killed by an ax,
but this time in the back of the hat,
Mrs Borden's blood was dry and medical
examiners estimated that she died in
roughly two hours before our husbands.
This would mean that the killer must
have been in the house the entire time
waiting for the perfect
opportunity to kill Andrew Borden.
Lizzy sister Emma was out of town
visiting a friend and they had to send a
telegram telling her to come home. She
had a solid alibi about our whereabouts,
so the police removed her as a potential
suspect. Rigid. The maid was home,
but she had nothing to gain
by killing her masters.
She was also removed as a
potential suspect by the police.
When the police arrived,
it was noted that no one in
the house was covered in blood.
If Lizzie Borden really
did kill her father,
she would have blood splattered
all over our clothes.
She would not have been able to clean
herself off within a matter of 10 minutes,
especially without any
running water in the house.
It's considering she was one of the only
people home at the time that she had
the most to gain from a parents' deaths.
All eyes were on her,
stood with their family members and her
father's business associates at their
parent's funeral.
Instead of watching their patterns
cascades get buried in the ground,
so the police, or did the bodies
be taken for a second autopsy?
The police also had free reign to search
the entire house from top to bottom,
and yet they couldn't find the murder
weapon or any solid evidence that would
prove the identity of the killer.
Lizzie Borden was questioned by the police
for several hours into answers where
sometimes inconsistent as if she
couldn't quite get her story straight.
The beliefs saw this as evidence
that she was lying. However,
her doctor had injected her with morphine
before each interview saying that it
would help calm her nerves.
These injections would have made her
feel mentally cloudy and confused.
In some cases, the drug can even
cause delusions and hallucinations.
Despite having this drug running through
her vein story still never confessed to
killing her parents
leading up to the trial,
I'm a Borden and Alice Russell witnessed
Lizzie Borden burning one of her
dresses in the back yard.
She claims that she was simply disposing
of old clothes that have paint stains
on them.
She gave the police the blue dress that
everyone had witnessed her wearing the
day of the murders and it was
completely free of bluffs.
They also never found a bloody
dress when searching the house,
but the police saw the burning of the
mystery dress as a sign that she may have
changed out of the clothes that she
kills her parents and she was trying to
destroy the evidence.
Lizzie Borden was arrested on suspicion
of killing her parents and she was taken
to a holding cell in a women's prison.
The dates of the trial where from June
5th to 20th of 1893 this was nearly a
year after the death of her parents,
a pharmacist named Eli.
Ben's testified in court that Lizzie
Borden requested to buy potassium cyanide
the day before the murder,
but he refused to sell it to her because
he suspected that she had terrible
intentions when the police exam to the
bodies of mister and missus board and the
autopsy report showed that they had
never been poisons. It was just bad food.
After all this meant
Mister Benz is claimed,
didn't improve that Lizzie did anything
wrong. Her neighbor and friends,
Alice Russell also testified against
her about burning the dress. However,
without having the actual dress on hands,
they still could not prove that there
was ever any blood on us after nearly a
year to prepare their case.
The police had nothing but circumstantial
evidence against her and it was simply
not enough to prove that she was guilty.
The members of the jury,
they were all men which
was customary at the time.
All of them had a very hard time
believing that the same woman who was the
Sunday school teacher could really be
the same monster who committed cold
blooded murder.
They fought him more likely there's a
prowler broke into the home and killed Mr
and Mrs Borden.
They only took 19 minutes to make
the decision that she was not guilty
for a parents' deaths.
Lizzie and ptosis to Emma split their
father's inheritance in half and it was
more than enough money to take care
of them for the rest of their lives.
They could finally afford
buy and luxurious house on
the hill called Maplecroft.
They also harder staff have maids
and the driver to take them anywhere.
They wanted to go in a horse drawn coach.
There's,
he changed her name to Elizabeth after
moving in in hopes of escaping her
reputation in her mind's the life on
the hill may have seems like a million
miles away, but the reality was
that they were still in fall river.
I reputation as a murderer. I continue
to follow her for the rest of our life.
Magazine's reported false rumors that
she was a shoplifter that she killed a
baby kittens and birds
when she was a child.
People did not want to sit in there and
charge and say our house was pummeled
with rotten eggs on a regular basis.
No one wanted to be associated with this
woman who may have murdered our parents,
local children.
They made up a rhyme without her murder
and enjoyed singing it outside the
window and it went. As such,
Lizzie Borden took an ax.
She gave her mother 40 wax
when she saw what she had done,
she gave her father 41 now,
despite all of the criticism,
Lizzie never moved away to escape the
ridicule and tried to make the best of her
situation.
She began attending plays at the local
theater and three parties in her new home
for the cast and crew. She seemed
to be particularly, in fact,
she waited with an
actress named Nancy Neil.
Neal was known for having a deep
voice and the masculine attitude,
which led some people to believe that
the two might have been having an affair.
It turns out that O'neil
was truly a great actress,
worthy of admiration there because she
eventually moved to Hollywood and start
in a few movies.
Even though Lizzie Borden was now wealthy
and living in a good part of town,
she continued to be single
for the rest of her life,
but she may have been
concealing a hit and romance.
The only real evidence of the latter
though was a letter that she wrote to a
female friend saying something
rather romantic. I dreamed
of you the other night,
but I Dan, not to put my dreams on
paper for some unknown reason. Them or,
and Lizzie got into an argument and Emma
decided it was time for her to move out
of fall river.
She moves far away to escape the bad
reputation that the board and then had
brought them.
The sisters never saw each other again.
Some people believe that this is proof
of Lizzy's girls and that she must have
confessed to Emma how are the MLF.
Shortly after one of Lizzy's big
parties in which the actress,
Nance O'neil was in attendance,
some people believe that it may be more
likely that she was caught in a lesbian
affair or and the simply
disapproved of her new lifestyle.
Lizzie Borden continued to live alone in
her Maplecroft mansion for the rest of
her life.
She died at the age of 66 she left a
significant portion of her estate to the
fall river animal rescue
league in her well,
she also left thousands of dollars to
each of our close friends and cousins.
Today.
Both our childhood home by the river
runs Maplecroft mansion were purchased by
an investor and turned into museums.
To this day,
people still speculate whether Lizzie
Borden truly kills her parents,
but we'll probably never know.
So I really hope you found this video
interesting as always at that like button.
If you did,
why not also subscribed to this channel
for brand new videos twice a week,
Mondays and Thursdays, and let us know
how we're doing in the comments below.
We'd love to hear from you suggestions
what you thought of this one,
what you thought of other ones.
Just let us know.
We'd love to hear from you and as always,
thank you for watching.
Yeah.